مياه صرف صحي تصب عند الرصيف البحري في
بيروت
ومع ذلك يتناوب اسعد وصيادون اخرون الجلوس
عند المصب المهم عندهم الحصول على الاسماك
دون اهتمام بالسموم التي تعوم فيها
طبعا اوقاتهم
الانسان والبحر في خطر اذا ووفق الخبراء
نحن بصدد مخالفه للقوانين والاتفاقيه
برشلونه لحمايه البيئه البحريه والمنطقه
الساحليه للبحر المتوسط التي وقع عليها
لبنان الت
لوث والسبب توقف محطات التكرير عن العمل
نتيجه للقطاع المستمر في التيار الكهربائي
مهجوره تبدو هذه المحطه صممت لمعالجه
الصرف الصحي في العاصمه وجزء من جبل لبنان
لكن غياب الكهرباء اوقف كل شيء فيها عجلات
مضخاتها تنتظر انجاز مشروع لتشغيلها على
الطاقه الشمسيه
في صعوبه اقل من هيك عم بصير فيها اعطال
وهاي الاعطال مع فينا نصلحها لانه عم نطلب
من صلحها عنا مشاكل كثير ماليه المصلحه
وبس صرف الصحي المياه بتروح على البحر
غير ان تلوث المياه في لبنان لا يقتصر على
الصرف الصحي وحسب بل يرتبط بازمه اعمق
تعود الى سنوات مضت غزت خلالها الملوثات
المتنوعه الانهر والسهوله الزراعيه ومياه
الري هذا كله بشكل خطوري على البيئه
البحريه بس كمان على الصحه العامه لانه
يؤدي الى انتشار امراض بين الكائنات
البحريه وطبعا بين العالم يكون عم بياكلوا
هالكائنات البحريه
التلوث احد وجوه الازمه الاقتصاديه
المستمره في لبنان ما جعل سكانه تحت رحمه
سموم طالت المياه والتربه والهواء كاترين
حنا الجزيره بيروت